nancy pelosi is being called out for
some serious hypocrisy new video shows
her
without a mask talking and hugging
people at a crowded
white house event that's after slapping
republicans several of them
with 500 fines for violating her house
floor
mask mandate republicans say pelosi
should follow the cdc guidance but the
speaker
isn't backing down we have a
responsibility
to make sure of that the house of the
representatives
chamber is not a petri dish
for the because of the selfishness of
some not to be vaccinated
all right so jesse is the white house
now a
petri dish or a super spreader event
yeah i had a boss one time in politics
and remember we used to be able to smoke
inside in offices
you know the boss would sit there and
smoke inside in the office i'm not
old enough for that i'm sorry i am you'd
be surprised
don't lie to us and everybody else had
to go outside but the boss is out there
just ripping cools in everyone's face
it's the same thing with nancy we're
tired of the mask shame game
it has lost its potency it worked
maybe in the fall but not anymore
vaccines are here baby and to the
democrats the masks were the vaccine
remember that was their deal the masks
but trump had the vaccine
and the vaccine actually works the mass
work about this much
only works inside and varied to a small
extent
are members of congress even that close
to each other where they need masks i
thought they all hated each other
is is is representative green
and aoc like face to face in a hallway
no everyone steers clear of each other
sometimes they get close well yeah i did
see you hear something about that
but for the most part no one's spreading
it in the in the chamber
so kennedy this is obviously nancy
pelosi is a woman who
only cares about power and she has this
opportunity to be a little petty and
she's using it yeah that's exactly what
it is katie it's petty
and this is why people hate congress and
this is why we can't have nice things
i did the math 72.3 percent
of all house members have been
vaccinated at least the ones who are
reporting it
i would say conservatively ten percent
have natural immunity after having
contracted the virus
so they are well above herd immunity in
the house
so either she doesn't understand science
she doesn't understand math
uh she knows something about about the
vaccine she's not telling people
she doesn't trust the vaccine or she
just is so petty and hates republicans
so much
that she'll do whatever she can to
engage in these childish games
you know what how about fix immigration
how about do something so kids don't end
up
in dhs facilities unaccompanied why
don't you do something so
people understand whether or not the
southern border is open or closed
do your job finding people 500 a pop
because they're not masked when you're
not masked
over it it's a tall ass kennedy so
juan what about the discrepancy here and
the two visions of what we've seen
well it seems you guys don't like nancy
pelosi but i don't understand what this
big fuss is all about i really don't
because to my mind let's make a deal
uh you know what if the republicans in
the house
get vaccinated then nancy pelosi will
lift
the mask rule for the house floor right
now what we've got is less than half of
the republicans in the house of
representatives
saying that they have been vaccinated
the house doctor doesn't mean that i
don't have it
yeah nancy pelosi is right that we
need a mass mandate until we can be
assured
that the majority of the people on the
house floor
not more than the majority at least 70
85 percent
have been vaccinated and right now
they're not 72
in fact 85 of senate republicans say
they've been vaccinated
but it's less than half of house
republicans so
they're trying to make a political
statement they don't want to be
vaccinated well there's going to be a
consequence
and the doctor agrees with pelosi so why
why does she care
the rest of the country has been asked
to move to an honor system so it doesn't
really make sense that we can't trust
our own members of congress to do the
right thing and follow cd guidelines
on their own katie one quick thing
they said i'm going to ask you jillian
uh let jillian let me get you
one they have not reported it's not that
they haven't had it they they have not
reported
right different i was just going to get
the same point that kennedy did
about how just because you don't say
that you have it doesn't mean that
you're not vaccinated
a lot of people think it's just nobody's
business what their health records are
and what their health decisions are
that's true um but jillian the white
house today
tried to make to try to actually do some
damage control on this today by saying
we're open
everything is normal we're getting back
to normal now after that video came out
yes i would actually so katie sometimes
people put things
into more succinct words than you could
ever hope so i
got this tweet for you he's named rory
cooper i don't know who he is he's on
twitter he's a genius he says
if you're worried about people not
wearing masks
get vaccinated if you're vaccinated then
you don't need to worry about who's
wearing masks
that kind of sums it all up well that's
what i just said jillian so i must be a
genius too
oh sorry i wasn't listening
no one does it's okay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else